über diese rede von präsident joe biden
kann ich nun sprechen mit peter beyer er
ist koordinator für transatlantische
beziehungen der bundesregierung guten
tag herr meier grüße sie nachbarn ja
zunächst mal ganz offen gefragt herr
beyer was waren für sie die wichtigsten
akzente dieser rede von joe biden
zunächst einmal die bilder mit einer
vize präsidentin und einer speakerin
hinter ihm die übrigens letztere nicht
am ende das redemanuskript zerrissen hat
wie es noch vor vier jahren bei donald
trump gewesen ist und inhaltlich haben
wir so gut wie nichts zu außenpolitik
gehört mich hat das nicht überrascht
es geht ja im wesentlichen darum hier um
politische dinge anzusprechen und seine
rescue plan eine wirtschafts
wiederaufbaupläne und sozialstaat
stärken pläne an den mann zu bringen und
dafür zu werben das hat er getan
ja er will ja jede menge dollar in die
hand nehmen um die infrastruktur in den
usa zu verbessern herbei was heißt das
für die deutsche wirtschaft kann sich da
die deutsche wirtschaft auch viele viele
aufträge freuen
ja ich werde nicht zu optimistisch wir
alle kennen ja die aus den letzten vier
jahren dass die vereinigten staaten
unter donald trump den protektionismus
muss gerade im handel sehr stark
befleißigt haben und da ist noch wenig
bis nichts abgebaut worden wir wissen
auch dass bei american von vielen
gesehen wird als ein nur graduell
abgestuftes america first trotzdem bin
ich da nicht ganz so pessimistisch
wissen sie bei vielen dieser
potenziellen aufträge wenn es auch um
öffentliche vergabe von aufträgen geht
werden deutsche firmen mindestens wenn
sie mal in den usa ansässig sind mit
tochtergesellschaften schon zum zug
kommen ich glaube schon dass es hier
auch möglichkeiten für deutsche
wirtschaft gibt sich hier einzubringen
einfach auch weil klar ist deutsche
firmen haben sehr viel know how die
weltweit geschätzt wird
jetzt haben sie ja vor der wahl das
gebaren des alten präsidenten sehr
deutlich beklagt und kritisierte joe
biden ist jetzt seit 100 tagen im amt
sie haben im vorfeld dieser rede gesagt
das wäre das ende der
eiszeit ja was hat sich denn jetzt ganz
konkret in den beziehungen zwischen
berlin und washington in diesen ersten
100 tagen verändert ganz konkret
natürlich das überrascht sie auch nicht
dass ich das denn anfangs stelle dass
der ton deutlich respektvoller ist
freundlicher ist das ist nicht ganz so
banal wie es sich vielleicht anhört
es ist schon entscheidende voraussetzung
dafür um sich eben gemeinsamen aufgaben
zu widmen und da nenne ich zum beispiel
eben dass wir verstärkt mit den
wirtschafts- und handelns dem ins
gespräch kommen müssen da ist mir noch
zu wenig übrigens von beiden seiten des
atlantiks wir haben gesehen dass ist ein
ganz starkes signal der verbesserung der
transatlantischen beziehungen
das lloyd austin der
us-verteidigungsminister hier nach
deutschland gekommen ist und ganz klar
den truppenabzug der noch von trump
verkündet worden war eine absage erteilt
hat im gegenteil er hat sogar 500
zusätzliche stationierung von
us-soldaten und soldaten angekündigt zur
stärkung auch unsere
sicherheitsinteressen hier
das sind mal ganz konkrete gute punkte
und wenn man auf die weltbühne insgesamt
geht dann sieht man natürlich dass der
multilateralismus die internationalen
organisationen beispielsweise auch das
pariser klimaabkommen wieder mit den
amerikanern an bord sind das sind ganz
wichtige konkrete politische schritte
aber joe biden hat was nord stream
angeht also diese gaspipeline durch die
ostsee
und auch was die verteidigungsausgaben
angeht kein zweifel daran gelassen dass
er da keine andere linie fährt als sein
vorgänger was heißt das für die
bundesrepublik
ich glaube jeder der sich vorgestellt
hat jetzt wird wieder alles besser hat
wahrscheinlich insgeheim gedacht die
deutschen und vielleicht auch ein stück
war die europäer können sich weiterhin
einen schlanken fuß machen
ich meine dass zwei prozent ziel bei den
verteidigungsausgaben der nato das ist
eine verpflichtung die wir selbst
eingegangen sind seine vertragliche
verpflichtung und deutschland
verlässlicher partner für sich selbst
aber auch die übrigen nato
mitgliedsstaaten sein muss und auch wird
da haben wir anstrengungen deutlich
erhöht also dass auch joe biden
weiterhin das einfordert ist etwas was
mich nicht nur überrascht sondern ich
will
das auch von uns selbst erwarten wollen
da sind wir glaube ich dann jetzt doch
an er ist gut unterwegs sie sprechen
nord team 2 an das ist so eine sache wo
ich mir auch erwartet hätte mit einem
regierungswechsel in washington dass wir
hier rascher zu konstruktiven gesprächen
kommen es gibt mittlerweile gespräche
aber noch keine konkreten
lösungsvorschläge deswegen plädiere ich
ja dafür auch wir hier sollten uns auf
die geänderten transatlantische
beziehungen insofern einstellen dass wir
nicht mit den gleichen textbausteinen
die wir in den tramp jahren angewendet
haben reagieren sondern lasst uns doch
ein fenster der möglichkeit eröffnen zu
einem gespräch konstruktive art über
nord team 2 übrigens vielleicht in einem
gesamten russlandpolitik paket und
deswegen sage ich es macht keinen sinn
nordteams war jetzt zu ende zu bauen
weil es einfach einen doch ein
stolperstein für den neustart in den
transatlantischen beziehungen ist das
ist realität
jetzt haben sie zwar angesprochen und
richtig analysiert das ist wenig akzente
in der außenpolitik gab trotzdem hat
beiden ausstellungen haben zum
verhältnis zu china und russland er
sagte man suche nicht den konflikt mit
dem land man hätte aber klargemacht den
letzten wochen dass bestimmte handlung
so hieß es bestimmte konsequenzen nach
sich ziehen also im verhältnis zu
russland und china steht der in
deutschland da jetzt an der seite
washingtons natürlich nicht nur jetzt
das haben wir ja schon den letzten zeit
immer wieder getan und signalisiert es
gibt hier nicht nur jene abstimmungen
sondern sie unterstützen natürlich sehr
klar auch die klare ansage klare sprache
wenn sie sich erinnern an die reden joe
biden seine erste außenpolitische rede
die er noch in seinem außenministerium
an der seite tony blinken gehalten hat
dann seine rede auf der virtuellen
münchner sicherheitskonferenz das sind
die dinge die wir sehr begrüßen und
bezug auf china haben jetzt die neuen
die neuen die neue regierung unter joe
biden in washington einen etwas anderen
ansatz als die vorgängerorganisation
weil sie nicht maximalen druck auf
europa aus wie gesagt ihr müsst ganz
klar ich abkoppeln von china da wird
schon gesehen dass wir hier große
interessen haben aber ich glaube wir
müssen mehr noch gerade beim china
dossier europäer und amerikaner
identifizieren wo sie denn gemeinsame
interessen beispielsweise bei der
unterdrückung von minderheitenrechten
bei der demo niederschlagung der
demokratiebewegung in hongkong beim
diebstahl von geistigem eigentum das
sind dinge die können wir sehr
zusammenführen in einer gemeinsamen
china politik ich plädiere dafür hat es
sehr sinnvoll
auch in unserem interesse dass wir eine
transatlantische china politik und eine
transatlantische einheitliche
russlandpolitik skizzieren und die auch
jetzt kraftvoll nach vorne bringen ja
dazu gibt es ja vielleicht im sommer
gelegenheit den job ein hat ja
angekündigt nach europa kommen zu wollen
peter baier war das zur rede von joe
biden die analyse dazu vielen dank dafür
und einen schönen tag noch nach ratingen